i think the dope thing about drake and
i've and i've watched it is that like
his
influence and what he pays attention is
all the way at the top he'll be rapping
about
[ __ ] sitting with like the guy who
pretty much owns the whole
music industry lucian grange and then
he'll still
won't be big enough to sub some i'm
gonna just say he's unknown because he
probably has like
15 000 followers in the city he'll sub
him on a song
and everybody won't even get it but for
that one guy and that whole city
they're like yo drake just killed you
like
just like there's this guy in toronto
and um like his whole thing is like yo
you can't face me like they talk a
little weird there
and drake drake drake said it on like i
think the lemon pepper freestyle
and he was just like yo face who like
you know i could fit and he just
violated him
nobody knows but that guy knows i'm like
how is drake still tapping into [ __ ]
like that like
you're supposed to be this guy who's
who's moving like
companies with your words and [ __ ] like
that but he still cares about that
well this is what i think is so
impressive with him and why he's able to
like maintain his status for so long
is that he basically births
the next generation of artists and
intertwines himself to those artists
and now they're forever indebted to him
because he's given him their first
number one
so these so it's like it almost behooves
him
to pay super close attention to who the
next generation is or the next type of
music coming out like he was popping on
the london ship for a minute
obviously me goes everybody's like oh i
want to do something with you
and he'll use his influence not only to
help himself but to help
other people but by helping them now
those people like yo drake's the man
like he he made me a millionaire drake
made me a millionaire how could i not
love him i've always said drake is the
best a
r in the game yeah this [ __ ]
like
every on everybody early he goes early
little baby early
is he the greatest rapper ever yeah yes
yeah instantly yeah and and
and the reason why i'm saying is that
we're not talking about just
when people hear that they instantly
just think about bar for bar like
you know i mean it's like when you think
about um
i think overall floyd might be the best
ever
but if you actually think about boxing
probably you know what i mean
probably who he probably isn't no floyd
is the greatest ever
i mean i think that's arguable i mean
some people would still like
what are you going off are you just
going off technical skill are you going
off
um the fact that he's undefeated are you
going off
he's you're going up that's his point
his point is you got to be on time
but here's the thing with with floyd
with me is like i not only think floyd's
the best boxer ever i think floyd is the
best
person at any task ever i think floyd is
better at boxing than jeff bezos is in
business
i think floyd's better boxing than elon
musk is at building spaceships
i think floyd is better at boxing than
davinci was
davinci wasn't invented [ __ ] like when
you say boxing
i think he's the best at boxing as in
seeing the whole game
and playing it right i think the
conversation
if floyd took certain fights and may
have lost
and his record wasn't 50-00 but
43-7 very different we don't even talk
about it but nobody's meeting him
but here's the thing though there was a
strategy his approach to the game was
also
like up there with his skills in the
ring you get me and i think with drake
when i say he's the best rapper ever i'm
not only talking about like just
rapping i think he's seen the game and
done all the necessary things
to capitalize and be at the top
okay we there's really only one other
person you can compare it to right is
drake or j
right what is the fruit that has come
from jay's tree
what is the fruit that has come from
drake's tree but is that
are you counting that though i'm just
curious of it because the one knock on
tape
i count that legacy but i don't count
that in you being a rapper
no no no i don't think in terms of skill
i'm just well okay let's stay on just
who's the best ever
so you know i think you're talking about
like in terms of what jay
has done that has he's left with the
game
i agree but i don't count that in being
the best ever yeah yeah i i think that's
fantastic i think that's fair count that
in your run
and whether your run was assisted by hey
in years you were a week you put your
hand around a hot guy
or years like you were weak and you
switched genres or whatever the [ __ ] you
did
drake made sure he had a ironclad hold
on the game
consistently for 10 plus years and
jay was one of always one of the top
five
yeah yeah some years he was one some
years it was two some years he was three
but i think what he gave to the game
in terms of people influence um
his impact people cloud their
their thoughts and thinking about it to
say he's the best but that's just his
legacy
i might you look at it as a knock
when i say that like drake did this with
these other artists
i don't look at it as a knock i i think
that what he did is
unbelievable like those other artists
got way more out of it than drake did
like he gave them tons of exposure
you're talking about like you're talking
about a
world superstar going on and going on a
song with a guy who's hot
in a small portion of the population
like
maybe within that population it's like
the oozy [ __ ] like you were saying like
uzi's selling 3 000 tickets he's not
selling out arenas but the whole world
is like
can't stop talking about uzi you let me
know if
if i'm describing this enough okay i'm
describing it as
for example it's like teaming up in the
nba yes
like people want to see lebron not have
no one on his team and just always be
cleveland champions the moment he says
a.d come over here oh
[ __ ] he's you know what i mean but that
is smart yeah but i think what we're
looking at with
with drake is that
we can't like we give him props for like
helping other artists but we're like
that artist could have competed with you
at some point
you get me yeah and that's what i'm
saying rock him asleep
because there's a point that in 2015 if
you go back when future was
so hot if you if
you could have forecasted you'd be like
yo maybe future could if he keeps us up
and
keeps ascending maybe he could topple
drake
no i don't think i did well
but drake pretty much overshadowed his
way
travis i think baby to a certain extent
people are start
charlemagne said that about baby like he
believes baby's a guy i don't believe
baby's guy yet
no but i think drake is smart
drake won't ever make it like lines in
the sand i think he'll he'll always
collaborate help and he'll always have
those moments with that person
knowing he's going to outlast him he's
like floyd in a way floyd never knocks
the [ __ ] out but he's like yo
you go 12 with me
by the 12 round [ __ ] gonna know i won
right like
yo maybe the first couple of rounds
that's diabolical that's brilliant
that is the next level diabolical that's
why he's one of the best
if not if you can't beat him join them
join them so they can't be
you you yeah but you also got to believe
in your [ __ ] you also got to believe
when you on the track with every one of
these [ __ ] you're gonna be
nicer
you gotta believe ev because that is
immense self belief
because if you're willing to go on the
same song with all these different
people
you're basically saying i'm better i'm
better
you know what's funny though like drake
hopped on
he dropped this last track with baby i
was disappointed because of that baby
baby watched him baby killed him washed
him washed baby doesn't resonate with me
i don't get it but we're 37.
so i don't think we're supposed to i
think the way drake capitalizes is
because
you know how an old rapper you can
hear his music and it sounds a little
dated they can't stay with the time so
what drake can capitalize on is like
hey if i get on a song with this person
who has a hot sound right now
i can now take this sound and it doesn't
look like me copying because we're
collabing on the sound
and he was getting accused of that when
he was doing a lot of that london [ __ ]
and so he has lasted because now i can
stay with
all the new sounds that are going on
because i'm just hopping on a new guy
but then i could also come back to my
singing [ __ ] my emo [ __ ]
and so it's like album never sounds like
his features his plan
is perfect it's like dave portnoy it's
it's important yeah
he's like yeah i'm gonna do a tick tock
podcast you guys 45. like he doesn't
take tuck
yeah he does a podcast josh richardson
or whatever
performance i'm such a [ __ ] hippie
bro
here i am thinking he's trying to spread
the burning man love
no help other people's careers and the
whole time he's like i'm
riding a goddamn wave somebody told me
this about drake
and and i think it's it's very true
i do think he's at a he's at a
interesting point in his career
and it's the point of his career where
for the people like me who like him and
love him like
as i said drake is the greatest of all
time
you're now about to hit your 30s or
you're in your 30s yeah
the new kids drake is cool but he ain't
young boy
he ain't baby mm-hmm he ain't is that
true
yeah yeah thanks i mean for the new kids
yeah drake is cool like they're like
okay
it's like i remember when when i came in
hip hop i was like oh jc is cool but why
y'all riding his dick like yeah
i was just gonna say he's not
revolutionary anymore you know what i
mean like
i think for my generation it's like yeah
yeah and it's like how do you
you know what's crazy you type in drake
to
to instagram and it doesn't come up you
have to type in champagne
poppy you already have like 50 million
followers
but still he's at that point where and
you realize how much demographics matter
because
it's who the kids love now and and
what was told to me which i i kind of
agree was like yo
the kids who love say a young boy or
baby
they'll never love drake more than those
guys okay they might like drink he's the
kids
he's 24 years old i mean but kids are
even younger than me but yeah
so your generation little hip-hop let me
introduce what what you don't realize
this is one of the reasons why i mean
hip-hop like
when you're 24 you're busy with a job
you're not affecting hip-hop yeah you're
you do have consumer money but you're
not on message boards you're not on
you know instagram tick tock if you have
a full-time job and come home doing
tick-tock dances you got problems yeah
it's high schoolers listen up nurses
homework
and i would say college high schoolers
in college
dictate the conversation of hip-hop
after you leave college now you have the
money to spend
so that's why some people don't care
about being a conversation as long as
they get people like him
you